in order for the coherence of the world
to exist that first part has to be
sacrificed and so why does it have to be
sacrificed the best way to understand it
is that it has to be given up four
things to exist properly they have to
exist in something which is beyond it if
it's going to reach its Highest
Potential its Highest Potential is
something like giving itself to
something that it's not
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
I'm really excited to announce that we
have just put up the new symbolic World
website this new website you know marks
the return of the blog symbolic World
blog the return of the reading list and
also a brand new symbolic World
Community which is accessible and will
be hosted directly on the website this
community can be accessed by anybody who
subscribed to the symbolic world for
those who are who were already
subscribed and supporting us a different
level of patronage either through PayPal
patreon or subscribe star all you need
to do is put in your email address you
will get a reset link for your password
and you are in and for everyone
everybody else it seems like a good time
to join the symbolic world to access all
these new things we're also offering a
few new gifts to everybody who
subscribes even at the level of free
subscriber just to thank everybody for
all the support you have given us all
through all these years and I have to
say it's just beginning we will soon be
announcing new courses uh you know
Richard Roland is preparing a course on
Beowulf there are all these new projects
the new Snow White Project God's dog and
the symbolicworld.com will be the place
to follow this and to get news and you
know some uh a few Peak sneak peeks at
what is coming in the future so thanks
everybody for support and like I said
we're just starting
so hello to all of you it's been a while
since I've come back to Exodus and since
for me at least today it is Holy
Thursday I thought that um going on the
next step of my own Exodus comment would
be a good idea and we are looking at the
last plague which is the death of the
firstborn this is of course Very Much
related uh to the Passover and to pasca
to Easter for Christians as well and so
I'm going to look at the text in Exodus
we're going to talk a little bit about
you know
what some of the things that are going
on there are so many things happening in
that text that I don't think I can
address all of them but at least the
notion of the death of the firstborn you
know why is this a part of the story and
how it relates also to posca for
Christians why is it that we know we
think the crucifixion is the final
version of this story uh and what that
means for us
and so as we start we start in Exodus
chapter 11 I'm going to kind of read
through it you know and then start to
comment on it
and so the Lord said to Moses and Aaron
in Egypt this month is to be for you the
first month the first month of your year
tell the whole community of Israel that
on the 10th day of this month each man
is to take a lamb for his family one for
each household if any household is too
small for a whole land they must share
it one with their nearest neighbor
having taken into account the number of
people there are you are to determine
the amount of the Lamb needed in
accordance with what each person will
eat
and so what's important to understand is
you right now at the outset is that this
is of course related to the beginning
right it's this is a new beginning it is
the new year and so a lot of the
symbolism in the uh Passover will have
to do with a new beginning and uh and it
will have to do with the kind of Purity
um and then also the sacrifice of the
firstborn is related to a new beginning
in a strange way that we will see as we
get there
um
and so it's important the reason why
it's saying that you need to calculate
how much land you need for each person
is that the idea is that you have to eat
all the lamb you can't leave any
leftover and that of course is related
to the notion of beginning or the
creation of identity it's like we need
the identity the identity to be uh to be
manifested the beginning to be clear and
we don't want there to be remainder and
so the animals you choose must be year
old males without defect and you may
take them from the sheep or the goats
take care of them until the 14th day of
the month
when all the members of the community of
Israel must slaughter them at Twilight
then they are to take some of the blood
and put it on the sides and tops of the
door frames of the houses where they eat
the Lambs
that same night they are to eat the meat
roasted over the fire along with bitter
herbs and bread made without yeast do
not eat the meat raw or boiled in water
but roast it over a fire with the head
legs and internal organs do not leave
any of it till morning if some is left
till morning you must burn it this is
how you are to eat it with your cloak
tucked into your belt your sandals on
your feet and your staff in your hand
Eden haste it is the Lord's Passover
so there are a few things that are
difficult in my own estimation to kind
of understand but there are a few things
which seem to me pretty clear of course
the idea is that you have to eat the
whole thing and you also have to be
ready you have to be ready for this new
beginning which is upon you which means
that you know you have to be girded the
idea of girding your loins you know we
we it's a funny thing to think about but
you have to imagine people wear these
robes and everything is kind of loose in
there but if you're going to do
something definite right if you're going
to do something that requires uh action
and focus then you need to hold things
together down there and this is not
arbitrary it has to do with you know
Gathering Together things that are loose
and that is what is going on in the
symbolism of a new beginning you know
you kind of gather things together so
that you have a focus so you have an
identity so you have a new beginning
with the beginning of this new year
um and this has to do with the idea of
Fire uh you know the idea of cooking it
with fire and the idea that none of it
has to be left that it has to be a
holocaust that it has to be fully
consumed either by the people or by fire
so that there is no remainder no
leftover
and so of course we are looking at the
fact that the Egyptians did not do this
did not take this this lamb and did not
put the blood of the Lamb on the pillars
of the house and so you know this idea
of you know covering the the posts of
the door the post of the entrance of the
house with the the blood of this lamb
which is the firstborn which is this
this beginning which is the the the the
new beginning
um you know it's it's hard and it's
obscure for us because it's so different
from the way that we think but if we
kind of look at it we can kind of see a
glimmer of what is going on there you
know why is it that
this ritual of a new beginning why it
has to You Know cover the the door as a
kind of identity as an identifying Mark
marking those that are inside
uh you know for this new beginning so
that when death comes and the end of
Egypt comes the end of of there of the
plagues come then those that are marked
by that identity will not be taken over
by death you know and so you can
understand it just in terms of
you know just in terms of how that is in
some ways how we avoid death all the
time that is how we avoid fragmentation
and breakdown and scattering is that we
are marked by an identity we're a marked
you know on the entrance on the place it
marks the limit between inside and
outside that's what the door is there is
a mark which binds us to that place and
which binds us together and so we can
understand it in that way as a kind of
identifying Mark which is related to
this new beginning and this identity
which is which is burgeoning so uh you
know
hopefully we can't completely see I
think for most of us it's hard to kind
of see through this but you know there's
enough I think to kind of understand
what is going on here
so on that same night I will pass
through Egypt and strike down the ver
every firstborn of both people and
animals and will bring judgment on all
the gods of Egypt I am the Lord the
blood will be assigned for you on the
houses where you are and when I see the
blood I will pass over you no
destructive plague will touch you when I
strike Egypt
and so once again the firstborn of Egypt
which represents the seed of Egypt right
it represents the firstborn represents
the identity right it is the first thing
to break the womb it is the first
fruit of the Union the first fruit of a
family and this idea of first and
identity is very much related to it
think of you know the idea of the first
in the sense of the first and the
hierarchy
think of a king or something like that
that represents the the culmination
point of something just as the beginning
represents the origin of something and
so you can kind of understand why the
firstborn is an image of Egypt itself is
an image of the seed of Egypt you could
say right the big the the thing the the
place where Egypt Finds Its name its
identity and so this is what God will
uh go for but then it's also a judgment
on the gods of Egypt because those are
related right the the idea of the Gods
as the principalities and the idea of
the firstborn as acting in a similar way
you know as a kind of principality in
the sense of you know the one who
carries the father into the future the
one who cares the identity you can kind
of see how that works together and the
fact that the that the Israelites have
this Blood of the Lamb on their door on
the as a mark between the inside and the
outside means that they will be
preserved in their identity preserved in
their seed as the Egyptians are uh being
judged and being decimated
this is a day you are to commemorate for
the generations to come you shall
celebrate it as a festival of the Lord a
lasting ordinance
now this is it seems obvious you know
but
I've pointed many times to the
relationship between the idea of
identity the idea of that which marks
inside and outside the common binding of
a group or of any anything that
recognizes that it has identity and the
idea of
celebration
but also of memory right these are these
these themes are all related and so God
is telling them it's not just that
you're going to do this it's that you're
going to do this it's going to Mark you
in your identity and then you are going
to celebrate it every year so you're
going to Mark time with this ritual with
this event the event that is the new
your new beginning so that you can
maintain that new beginning right it's
something like uh you know it's the same
thing with the idea of celebrating you
know your national holiday or
celebrating something which marks some
origin for you Mark's uh you know your
identity and by commemorating it and
remembering it and celebrating it you
maintain its reality in your life you
make it participate in in your life and
make makes you remember even though
you're far away from the actual event
that happened you remember so that you
participate right so you can kind of
understand the relationship between that
of course and Christian communion as in
some ways the ultimate memory or the
ultimate participation because we the
Christian
um let's say the Christian communion
actually collapses
collapses the memory not it doesn't
collapse or it has Perfect Memory in the
sense that we say it is the blood and
Body of Christ it is in some ways a
memory of it but that memory is so full
right that it becomes it it merges with
the very thing so it's like a there's a
paradox in it it's like we do this in
remembrance of uh the sacrifice of
Christ but we are participating in the
sacrifice of Christ and because it is in
some ways the perfect sacrifice and it
is in some ways you know the actions of
God himself we we enter into it fully in
a way that brings it together completely
right so it is both Bread and Wine and
it is at the same time the bread and and
the body and blood of Christ at least in
Orthodox thinking we don't have exactly
the same type of theology where we we
deny that it's bread and and wine we say
it is Bread and Wine and it is the body
and blood of Christ and these these
things are coming together in this
Perfect Memory okay
so all of this of course will like I
said all this kind of idea of
remembering the Passover will be brought
into Christianity at a at a different
level we could say
okay so for seven days you are to eat
bread made without yeast on the first
day remove the yeast from your house
from whoever eats anything with yeast in
it from the first day to the seventh day
must be cut from Israel on the first day
hold the sacred assembly and another one
on the seventh day do not work at all on
these days except to prepare food for
everyone to eat that is all you may do
and so why the yeast what's this yeast
thing so of course the yeast is a
strange substance which you act which is
like it's like a bug you have to think
of it like a bug and this is something
that my brother matir has helped me
really understand because he did it
right he learned to make bread and
learned to play with yeast and learn to
understand what yeast is it is like a
parasite it's like this living thing
kind of bubbling living thing that you
have to keep alive uh and then you add
that to the bread and now what you've
added to the bread is something like
Thyme and you've also because you have
to wait now you you make you put the
yeast in now you have to wait for the
bread to grow oh and to like manifest
its fullness in in uh in time you could
say but here this is not what's going on
this is the beginning this is the
beginning of a new identity and so it it
has to do with Purity and it it's not
the rising of the bread right it's not
it's not the bread that kind of has
become full in time it is the like I
said it's the seed it's the identity
it's the marking of the difference
between Egypt and Israel the marking of
that of that identity and so I think for
sure pretty sure that that's why they're
the the notion that yeast and of course
just practically you can imagine they
didn't have time right they were they
were going to now the world was ending
this world was ending this new world was
beginning and so they kind of time kind
of collapses they don't have time to
wait they have to be ready they have to
be attentive and they have to be be
ready to leave Egypt as it is being
consumed and so all of this is not
contradictory of course there's a
relation between time and the the let's
say the strange or the parasite or that
which comes from the outside because it
is an it is an agent of
increase you could say for the identity
and so if you if you struggle to
understand that I suggest again to read
my brother's book which is which is the
best uh you can find on that the
language of creation all right and so
celebrate the Festival of unleavened
bread because it was on this very day
that I brought your divisions out of
Egypt celebrate this day as a lasting
ordinance for the generations to come in
the first month you are to eat bread
made without made without yeast from the
evening of the 14th day until the
evening of the 21st day for seven days
no yeast is to be found in your houses
and anyone with a foreigner or native
born who eats anything with yeast in it
must be cut off from the community of
Israel eat nothing made with yeast
wherever you live you must eat
unleavened bread so it's pretty clear
the idea is you you uh
you eat from the first month of the year
it's not clear to me why the days though
I mean of course all these things have
meaning but I don't totally understand
why it is from the 14th day until the
the 21st day and you know
I'm sure it has meaning sadly if anybody
has a good idea of what the days mean in
the months I would love to read your
comments and uh and learn from you but
at least for me I don't totally
understand but what I do understand is
you know at the beginning first month of
the year the beginning of this new
identity the celebration of this
identity all of this has to be done
without that which comes from the
outside and if you eat that which comes
from the outside this leaven which is
added to the bread then you will be cut
off from the identity you'll be cut off
from Israel from the identity so all of
this is makes complete sense
that Moses summoned all the Elders of
Israel and said to them go at once and
select the animal through family and
Slaughter the Passover Lamb take a bunch
of hyssop dip it into the blood in the
Basin and put some of the blood on the
top and on both sides of the door frame
none of you shall go out of the door of
your house until morning when the Lord
goes through the land to strike down the
Egyptians he will see the blood on the
top and sides of the door frame and will
pass over that doorway and you will not
permit the Destroyer to enter your
houses and Strike It Down
obey these instructions as a lasting
ordinance for you and your descendants
when you enter the land that the Lord
will give you as he promised observe
this ceremony and it's important to
understand what it's saying you know
it's relating the Passover right the end
of this Egyptian time the beginning of
this new identity to the moment when
they enter into the land because in some
ways what they're doing now will only
become fully active will only become
fully real when they become a nation and
they take the land that God had promised
them you know and so that's why it's
important that it says like when you
enter into the land that God has
promised you you have to obey the
destruction then and follow these
ordinances
and when your children ask you what does
this ceremony mean to you then tell them
it is the Passover sacrifice of the Lord
who passed over the houses of the
Israelites in Egypt and spared our homes
when he struck down the Egyptians
so remember right when your children ask
you remember that is how you stay
connected that is how you maintain your
identities by remembering the origin
remembering where you came from and
doing that celebrating that uh in also
even in ritual in ritual participation
the people Bow Down and Worship the
Israelites did just what the Lord
commanded Moses and Aaron now there's
interesting in terms of structure too in
the text because it's almost boring when
you read it because it's like on the one
hand it tells you
and on the one it tells you what the
rule is or what to do and then the
second hand is like well then they told
them to do that and then it's like and
then they did that you know uh but
that's the structure of what's going on
in itself it's like here's the pattern
here's the identity Here's the the the
thing and then it has to be enacted into
the world and there has to be memory of
it in order for this to take hold and
for for in order for it to remain real
for the people that participate in it
at midnight the Lord struck down all the
first born in Egypt from the firstborn
of pharaoh who sat on the throne to the
firstborn of the prisoner who was in the
dungeon and the firstborn of all the
livestock as well pharaoh and all his
officials and all the Egyptians got up
during the night and there was a loud
wailing in Egypt for there is not a
house without someone dead
during the night Pharaoh summoned Moses
and Aaron and said up leave my people
you and the Israelites go Worship the
Lord as you have requested take your
flocks and herds as you have said and go
and also bless me
very interesting way to end that
sentence you know
in some ways the Pharaoh is recognizing
what is happening at a very deep level
he's recognizing that you know the god
of Israel has struck him struck his
nation and is you know founding this new
nation doesn't totally understand it yes
but do you understand that there's
something new which is being born and so
that's why he doesn't just say go he
says go Worship the Lord and also bless
me
um
interesting
so the Egyptian urged the people to
hurry and leave the country for
otherwise they said we will all die so
the people took their dough before the
yeast was added and carried it on their
shoulders and kneading throughout
troughs wrapped in clothing the
Israelites did as Moses instructed and
acts asked the Egyptians for articles of
silver and gold and for clothing the
Lord had made the Egyptians verbally
disposed towards the people and they
gave them what they asked for so they
plundered the Egyptians and so I talked
about this in the previous video you can
go look at that uh I think in the last
video I talk about the notion of
plundering the Egyptians and what that
means
the Israelites Journey from Ramses to
sukhoth
there are about 600 000 men on foot this
is very important that there were 600
000 men the the addition of six is
important because it has to do with man
himself right it is in some ways a
number of man it is a number of work it
is the number that comes before the
Sabbath number before the seventh day it
is like it it's a number of men you
could say and so there were six hundred
thousand men on foot besides women and
children many other people went up with
them and also live large rows of
livestock both flocks and herds with the
dough the Israelites had brought from
Egypt they baked loaves of unleavened
bread the dough was without yeast
because they had been driven out of
Egypt and did not have time to prepare
food for themselves now it's also
important to understand you know that
they do end up leaving with this mixed
multitude and so the problem of like
identity and mixture is all through the
book of Exodus and the the question of
how that's going to come to a kind of
balance how we're going to balance the
inside and the outside the identity and
the stranger is going to be all through
and so you're right this idea remove the
yeast from yourself uh you know and also
there's a sense in which I I don't I
don't think we've read it yet no we'll
read it later that you know only
Israelites only those that have been
circumcised that the outside flesh has
been removed are allowed to participate
in this identity only those that have
removed their outer garments their their
participation in the the yeast you know
of the of their dough or whatever like
sorry to use weird analogies but just
understand that to do with inside and
outside that I've removed the outside
skin they are allowed to eat the
unleavened bread and participate in the
Passover the Passover meal
um
and any stranger who wants to do that
has to be circumcised in order to be
able to do that
um and so this is what we're gonna kind
of see right in some ways even the
circumcision of the mixed multitude into
the story of Exodus this is what's
related there are many waves of that you
could say of kind of weaning out the
outsider joining The Outsider with the
with the Israelites in different ways
um
and so now the length of the time these
Israelites people lived in Egypt was 430
years 41 at the end of
no at the end of 430 years to the very
day all the Lord's divisions left Egypt
because the Lord kept vigil that night
to bring them out of Egypt on this night
all the Israelites are to keep vigil to
honor the Lord for the generations to
come the Lord said to Moses and Aaron
these are the regulations the Passover
meal and so here we have a third like
regulation of the Passover meal no
Foreigner may eat it any slave you've
brought me bought may eat it after you
have circumcised him but a temporary
resident or hard worker may not eat it
he must be it must be eaten inside the
house right so take none of the meat
outside the house think in the
categories that I'm telling you and
you'll notice that all of these gestures
are making sense if we're talking about
the creation of a beginning the creation
of an identity do not break any of the
bones right do not don't break the hard
stuff inside uh the whole community of
Israel Israel must celebrate it so a
foreigner residing among you who wants
to celebrate the Lord's Passover must
have all the males in his household
circumcised then he may take part like
one born in the land no uncircumcised
male may eat it the same law applies
both to the native born and to The
Foreigner residing among you
so this is very important in that in
Israel the identity of becoming an
Israelite the identity of uh of joining
into that Covenant will be related to
circumcision that is it is circumcision
which is a kind of baptism which joins
you and makes you a child of Abraham
more than it is the idea that you're a
physical descendant of of Abraham right
you you join in through a ritual act
this is something that you know in our
own kind of biological thinking we
struggle to understand but this is not
something which would have been strange
to ancient people in any way
all the Israelites did just what the
Lord had commanded and Moses commanded
Moses and Aaron and on that very day the
Lord brought the Israelites out of Egypt
by their divisions
okay and so now we move into chapter 12
which is going to be the strange
consequence of the death of the
firstborn and of the
Passover and it's going to kind of help
us understand what is this death of the
firstborn and how is it that it can be
transformed in the proper way how can it
mean something more than just a kind of
plague that comes in and kills the seed
of the Egyptians
hello
the Lord said to Moses consecrate to me
every firstborn male
the first Offspring of every womb among
the Israelites belonged to me whether
human or animal
then Moses said to the people
commemorate this day you came out of
Egypt out of the land of slavery because
the Lord brought you out of it with a
mighty hand eat nothing containing yeast
today in the month of Aviv you are
leaving when the Lord brings you into
the land of the Canaanites hidites
amorites hivites and jebusites the land
he's where your ancestors to give you a
land flowing with milk and honey you are
to observe this ceremony in this month
and then he repeats it again
you don't want any yeast in your borders
on this day tell your son I do this
because of what the Lord did for me when
I came out of Egypt
this observance will be for you like a
sign on your hand and a reminder on your
forehead that this law of the Lord is to
be on your lips for the Lord brought you
out of Egypt with his mighty hand this
is a very very uh at least for
Christians this is a very profound
little verse here because he's he is
this is all coming together and
referring to the notion of a mark of a
sign which marks the inside and the
outside this idea of a mark on your hand
and a mark on your forehead will be
taken up by Christians in the Book of
Revelation as the mark of the beast like
that's where the mark of the beast is
and here it is in some ways the same it
is saying that you the observance this
memory of the beginning of your identity
the beginning of when you were separated
from Egypt when you became entered into
the land that God promised you be
entered into the Covenant that God made
with you that you have to keep it as as
a sign and you're on your head that is
the place you speak out of the place you
see of the place of Consciousness you
could say and your hand the place of
Your Action uh and then the law will be
on your lips and so right it's like it
has to do with with uh it has to do with
Consciousness it has to do with action
has to do with speaking but it also in
is referring to the idea of the mark
right that Mark that is put on the
lintels of the door is an extension of
Mark making itself there's a weird
relationship between that and The Mark
of Cain which is put on Cain to protect
him from death and so God puts a mark on
Cain to protect him from death and now
God puts a mark on Israel's door on the
the place that separates inside and
outside to protect them from Death it is
it is something that might seem strange
to you but it is important to kind of
understand that and to understand in
some ways how in the story of Christ all
of these all of these will uh collapse
let's say Christ will collapse all these
um
Christ will collapse all these these uh
these categories into his own sacrifice
okay
all right so after the Lord brings you
into the land of the canines and gives
it to you as he promised on oath to you
to your and your ancestors you are to
give over to the Lord the first
Offspring of every womb all the
firstborn males of your livestock belong
to the Lord redeem with the lamb every
firstborn donkey but if you do not
redeem it break its neck redeem every
firstborn among your sons
in the days to come when your son asks
you what does this mean say to him with
a mighty hand the Lord brought us out of
Egypt out of the land of slavery when
Pharaoh stubbornly refused to let us go
the Lord caleth the firstborn of people
and animals in Egypt this is why I
sacrifice to the Lord the first male
offspring of every womb and redeem each
of my firstborn sons and it will be like
a sign on your hand and a symbol on your
forehead that the Lord brought us out of
Egypt
with his mighty hand
so why is it that the death of the
firstborn in Egypt is also pointing to
the idea that all the firstborns belong
to God there's a very strange suggestion
in this text
which is that the firstborn of
of the of the people and the firstborns
of the animals should be sacrificed to
God
and that in order to avoid that you
redeem your firstborn with something
else right you you have a substitute for
the for something else and
um you know it's it's interesting
because you see that you know in certain
strands of theology they'll try to
make this related to like sin and you
know you you're your your sin is um
you you deserve to die because you're
sinful but then you know you something
is substituted for that sacrifice but
that's not what seems to be going on
here there's no mention of sin there's
no mention of
of uh of the law you know it's there's a
sense in which
the death of the firstborn or the giving
of the firstborn to God seems to be the
very at the very source of identity
seems to be at the very source of
separating Israel from Egypt and making
Israel you know the
the
the nation that it is you know
worshiping God and so why is it the
death of the firstborn
is necessary
um and so I'm going to give you one tack
at that it it's not the only one you
know there are this is a very deep deep
subject and so there are other ways to
look at it but I'm going to give you one
and it has to do with this idea of the
highest point of something
the origin of something
you know the top of the hierarchy you
could say
in terms of like I said in terms of
origin or in terms of first in terms of
that which carries the name further
right and so you kind of have this idea
that you know if a father has his
firstborn the firstborn is like the the
image of the father right he's like the
first fruit he's the he's the new
beginning he's all of this stuff and
there's a sense in which
in order for the the coherence of the
world to exist
that first part has to be sacrificed and
so why does it have to be sacrificed
the best way to understand is that it
has to be given up it has to be given up
to that which is before it and so in
some ways like the image of the first or
the beginning of something has to be
given to something which is even before
something which precedes it uh and the
the so why why is that and so it has to
do with the way that the world exists it
has to do with kind of this fractal
structure that I talk about all the time
uh which is that four things to exist
properly they have to exist
in something which is beyond it they
they always do anything that has unity
you know if it's going to reach its
Highest Potential its Highest Potential
is something like giving itself to
something that it's not right so an
example that is easy to understand is in
sports you so you have let's say you're
playing basketball I use that a lot as
an example you're using basketball and
you have different actions that you're
doing you have dribbling and you have uh
the running and you have passing the
ball and you have all these actions and
so the best of that right so like the
best of dribbling the best of of running
the best of passing the ball the one
that is closest to
what you're doing has to be given to the
purpose of basketball it has to be
sacrificed it doesn't exist for itself
right dribbling for itself is just
pointless and and nothing it has to be
it has to exist in that which is giving
it its identity and so you can
understand that this dribbling has to be
sacrificed to the game of basketball in
order for it to even have value and so
once you get that you can kind of
understand why it is that the firstborn
you know the firstborn of something the
highest of something has to be given up
is supposed to be sacrificed up to God
to in in order in order to give the rest
of the the world value in order to
Anchor the value of everything else okay
and so
so you can understand it that way there
are different ways to understand it
there are ways to understand it that are
that are very practical you can
understand for example that in a in a in
terms of war in terms of military so the
idea that you have to in order for your
country to exist you have to accept
sometimes that the best of your people
will die
for your country they will sacrifice
themselves they will give themselves
even unto death for the purpose of the
country to exist itself and that that
sacrifice will anchor the existence of
the of the of the the family and so and
that for example in in the Christian
world it was often the idea that you
know the families would hope that one
member one's son would become a priest
for example and so you think like in
terms of pure kind of practical you know
or first level evolutionary thinking it
seems like that's a contradiction why
would you want a child your child to
become a priest it means you won't have
grandchildren it means your seed won't
continue but there's a way a deeper way
of understanding reality which is that
the highest part of you know the highest
part or some aspect of the highest part
has to be given up and if it's given up
it will it will anchor the rest and so
if one of my child becomes a priest and
prays for us
then it will hold my family together
right and so you can unders if you're
not a religious person you can
understand it just like if there's one
person that isn't bothered by all their
own like personal family or whatever but
has is focused on a higher ideal then
that will anchor not just my family but
will also anchor Society will maintain a
a capacity to see through all the petty
little things that I deal with and will
ultimately kind of anchor my my Society
together my family you know the
different things that I participate in
and so this can be seen in Practical
terms but you can also understand why it
could be ritualized right you can
understand that for example when people
harvested their grain they knew that the
best part the first part has to be
sacrificed you don't eat it you you
sacrifice it for so that the next year
you can have another Harvest and you
know and so you can understand how this
type of gesture would easily become
ritualized and that the ritualization of
it would maintain it as a pattern in
society so if I know that I'm supposed
to sacrifice my firstborn
up to God then it it it creates that
pattern in my Society where I understand
the value of sacrifice the need for
sacrifice the need to give up the best
of what I have up to God and so you know
that can be something like the the
tithing for you know God talks about the
first part right the the first part of
your earnings should go to God there are
different versions of that in the Bible
that that manifest different aspects of
this idea that the first part has to be
uh has to be given up
um and so interestingly enough what
happens though is that there is an
uneasiness about this and there's this
sense in which you know we can redeem
the firstborn with something else and so
it it's like instead of killing my own
child instead of sacrificing my child to
God then I will offer something that's
lower on the hierarchy in order to
substitute that and so it's it's a it's
a it's a deeper ritualization right it's
like I I I know that this is important I
know that I do have to give up that
which is the most important to me or
that which is the highest but I do so I
take something lower instead in order to
in order because there's something I
mean why why does it why does it bother
it's like there's something wrong with
what's going on there's something that
is imperfect about about uh in some ways
about this system
um and I think that that's in some ways
what Christ is coming to
coming to heal because what Christ
ultimately says is that you don't
sacrifice your children you don't
sacrifice you sacrifice yourself right
that's what you have to sacrifice that's
the highest part of yourself that you
have to give up to God in you and then
that's the anchor of society not giving
your son or your lamb or whatever but
that the secret behind all of these
rituals is that you have to give
yourself up and that if you do that then
that becomes the best anchor for society
and that those that do that if you think
of the martyrs that don't give anybody
else up except themselves they become
the seed for the church and that that
type of behavior whether it's the
ascetics that give their life in prayer
to God uh you know it's a it is a kind
of of sacrifice a kind of self-sacrifice
which then becomes the seed for for the
church to exist and for society to kind
of find their find a a guide or find a
let's say find beacons to look at in
order to model our our own behavior and
so
now what happened of course in the story
of Christ is that Christ takes up all
this symbolism into the crucifixion of
course everybody knows that the
crucifixion itself is happening during
the time of Passover right yeah this is
this is what is is going on and so
Christ becomes the
lamb
that he becomes also the death of the
Egyptians he becomes both at the same
time and this is what makes that story
so difficult to understand because in
the story of the Egyptians the way to
understand it is something like
if you don't give up the first part if
you don't give up the highest part to
that which is above you it will be taken
from you
right and that's just true you know if
uh you know think about again the
basketball game so if you just love to
dribble and you just love to dribble and
you don't know and you don't give up
that action up to the game of basketball
then it's it's gonna be pointless it's
gonna be taken away from you No One's
Gonna Want You To Dribble like there's
been no value in dribbling it's going to
lose its very value on its own
if you don't give it up it's just going
to happen and that's true of everything
right if if you for example think that
you're gonna buy a nice car and a nice
house and you think that just doing that
for itself like without putting your
money or your your riches to the service
of a higher purpose then at some point
you're just gonna lose it all maybe not
the money but you'll find yourself in a
a position where these things will not
have any flavor for you anymore right
where the newest car with the newest
girl will just not bring you any Joy
because it's not sacrificed it's not
given up towards a higher purpose you
know and that's what you see right the
cliche of the of the of the rich person
or the movie star that has everything
they want but because they're they they
have everything is in service of
themselves and not in service of higher
Goods then they Panic you know and they
then they start to do things for
Charities or whatever which is great
which is what in some ways you would
want to see happen uh but but that is
the sign that if you don't give up then
it's taken from you but what happens in
the story of Crisis and it's just all
kind of weirdly it all collapses right
so so Christ is the one who receives who
who on the one hand
is the Lamb that is given but he's also
the one that receives the the Wrath of
the of God
and here I'm Orthodox saying that who
receives the on the night of passover
right it's like
the the let's say the dark thing passes
and and he's the one who who gets it so
he also plays the role of the Egyptian
uh children
the Egyptian firstborn
um
so he's the firstborn in every way and
then there's also
the idea that this you know let's say
finishes the idea of sacrifice and so
after the the death of Christ very soon
the whole sacrificial system will
collapse not just for Christians but for
Jews as well you know and and the
sacrificial system will cease to exist
now you can give excuses for why that
happened in different in different
places but if you understand the
symbolism what is going on on the cross
you'll understand that it is in a way
the culmination but then also the end of
the of the sacrificial the animal
sacrificial system and the commemoration
of the bread right that is eaten at the
Passover
becomes the sacrifice itself like it's
joined with the sacrifice and so all the
symbolism gets crunched together in ways
that is very like I said it's hard like
if you keep thinking about it I'm just
giving you a few examples but you if you
keep thinking about it of how the
crucifixion collapses the symbolism of
past over crunches it all together uh
you're going to you're going to find it
very uh
you're going to find it very interesting
um
and so those are just a few thoughts
let's say on the idea of of the Passover
the relationship between the death of
the firstborn why how it's related to
the the crucifixion a little bit this is
something I hope that you'll continue to
think upon as we at least for the
Orthodox as we come uh right up to pasca
and so I hope you have a a great end of
Holy Week and I will see you on the
other side bye-bye